this just in gang we are going to be a
part of the new york comedy fest here in
new york city november 9th you can get
tickets to come and see us at gotham
comedy club november 9th gonna be a
fantastic time yes and also don't forget
october 27th we're going home baby the
boys are going back to philly helium
comedy club one show only get tickets
that's close to selling out new york's
gonna sell out philly's gonna sell out
let's go get your tickies
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians when
we find enough they grow up to be classy
yeah or if they're just a big old piece
of trash
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day down here in auntie's
basement the fall is in the air
she's doing some home brewing oh yeah
pumpkin beer she's making with a secret
ingredient she's doing upstairs in the
bathtub
shout out to teddy secret ingredient she
says it's nutmeg i'm pretty sure just
fentanyl okay my co-host is coming at
you from right next to me he is the ceo
of are you garbage unamused i must say
no i like that one he's an international
businessman ah he's my best pal in the
whole world and i love him give it up
for kevin james ryan hey gang happy to
be here thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true
though [ __ ] roof baby and then
obviously uh sweet lord don't say it the
greatest website ever invented a shout
out to www.patreon.com
are you garbage shout out to the yam
family all the subsidiaries great people
god bless them we love you and how about
a quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man he makes us
all look good give it up for d-bone
mcmuffin toby
mcmullen
what's up dudes what up bro t-bone good
to see you and gang let me tell you
something we could not be more excited
and i mean not be more excited to have
our incredibly special guest here with
us today he is one-third of the hot new
amazing podcast called the loud boys
podcast over there on the gas digital
network
but the big question in his mind today
is he garbage talk about a home game
we gotta fed the rights
ladies and gentlemen give it up for mr
dalton pruitt
howdy how are you man thanks for coming
i'm good i want to clarify we're not on
gas digital we are
partners
we are oh boy we are partners kids
digital
we but we are we but we are on patreon
oh shout out to patreon so
go to the patreon subscribe to the loud
boys patreon.com backslash the loud boys
oh yeah very nice awesome we didn't like
my fentanyl joke i liked it iced me
every whole room iced me trying to look
good in front of the well we've lost so
many people
she's taking a nap right now oh my god i
apologize for my misstep i'm throwing
i'm i'm taking swings here i like it um
don't give us the back story i'm excited
for this you're a texas boy right oh yes
yes i've seen your feet my feet are
[ __ ] up yeah man bye they look like
something of a hollywood costume
designer yeah they look like a crocodile
to gargle
they haunt my dreams you know it's it's
not as painful as it looks it looks so
painful it looks your fingers look
pretty you've never seen them toby toby
google them okay
[Laughter]
put them up in variety okay and i'll put
them on the screen if
i think it's i don't know we might get
flat we might not get ads
this one
yeah i mean yeah this is going on
rotten.com
it's a family show t-bone yeah what the
[ __ ]
it's like something you see on ebon's
world back in the day yes
so give us a scoop so you grew up in
texas give us the whole deal how old are
you by the way i'm 28. 28. oh okay look
young though thank you i would have
pegged you for like 27. i couldn't tell
you had me and i'da pegged you
[Laughter]
welcome to ayg after i couldn't tell if
you were older you got you got a
hezbollah vibe to you you have a
babysitter i do have a hezbollah
oh yeah
i grew up in texas for the most part my
heart's in texas but uh that's trash for
the most part yeah yeah yeah we we
bounced around before we saw before we
settled down in the uh
in the west
statue of limitations was waiting to run
out yeah no
where in texas i grew up in a little
town called springtown texas
where where what's close to that nothing
[Laughter]
nothing that's right next to nothing
texas we didn't even we didn't even have
alcohol it was a dry county what yeah
yeah
when i was growing up i think it's since
changed but
when i was growing up there it was a dry
county because of the lord
and i never liked that guy yeah
and so if we wanted booze like my
friend's dad would have to drive us like
a half hour into azel texas that's where
the [ __ ] goddamn hornets play
the
hazel hornets
mortal enemy to the the springtown
porcupines
sounds like a simpsons
episode i feel like you're from the
multiverse
that was our high school football
arrival the azel hornets the green
hornets was it a big football town it
was it was it six man or was it full
because some of those towns in texas
well it was three-man football
population it was a town it was a town
where there was like nothing in it but a
lot of people live there that would like
commute to fort worth for their jobs so
there were a lot of families there okay
but it was like out you know still the
country but there were still a lot of
families there so it was a 4a
like football high school okay
you know so it was a big deal yeah yeah
pep rallies i was in marching band wow
what'd you play trumpet
an aristocrat yeah i like how you used
to trumpet yeah like it was d-line
it's
it's a surprisingly difficult instrument
to play
i'll have you know yeah
it really hurts
after a while when you say your your
your buddy's dad would drive you to get
beer are we underage at this point of
course yeah that's texas baby yeah yeah
catch up fatty like so they sound like
the age they couldn't even drive
oh no we were like 17. and he was cool
with that oh yeah were the cops real
ball busty about to drinking
no there was probably one car our
drinking happened in the like in a barn
like the cops weren't coming out to the
middle of it like
the cows weren't fired noise complaints
my friends bought my friend had
converted his dad had converted their
barn into like a little saloon there was
a pool table
yeah there was a whole lot i would love
to have a couple of pops oh my god dude
it was the best like week weekends or i
guess just every night really
in high school
we were at the barn just drinking
keystone lights until we blacked out
that's america baby yeah usa so we're
talking small town small town yeah the
the the attitude towards drinking was
that like well we know you're gonna
drink and we'd rather you do it here
yeah but it was like
but that's like drinking is the only
thing to do in this town so it's like if
you didn't buy it for us
we wouldn't drink
like we don't we don't have anywhere
else to go sure a movie theater no there
was no movie theater no we had to drive
you had to drive to
weatherford
ah the lovely kind of weather that was
maybe the closest movie theater about
about 40 miles i think what i don't know
i forget how far weatherford was doesn't
matter that's a hike
yeah i don't know if you guys are prepar
i've listened to this show and you're
you're metrics of garbage yeah we're
playing t-ball yeah it's it's like
i'm i'm scrambling even think right now
because it's like it's all garbage sure
the whole childhood well the south plays
by its own rules you have to braid on a
curve when it comes to the south it's
definitely different than like boston
trash what did your mom and dad do
um my mom
was a secretary until she wasn't and
then she just that's a tough that's such
always a tough one yeah she was still
she wasn't well yeah because i remember
because like i i didn't grow up
all the way ever i didn't grow up ever
no i wasn't what are you peter pan we
didn't we didn't move to texas i was in
like fifth grade and so
i was born in georgia in a little town
called vidalia and we hopped around a
bit because of my dad's job always
transferred him which is why
he was a federal prison guard
federal yeah
he started at the georgia state prison
and worked his way up to federal which
meant we had to move around quite a bit
that's probably a good job good job no
no no no no benefits
oh yeah i mean pay is good benefits but
it's like he would come home and tell us
like what was happening in his life
he shouldn't be doing that no you
shouldn't be your seven-year-old child
you shouldn't he would tell the stories
that's your night night story yeah for
real he would come home and tell us
about like inmates throwing [ __ ] at him
or cutting their own nuts off or like
getting into fights with inmates like
riots and [ __ ] ms-13 was everywhere
he had these horrifying stories he would
like
like looking back on it yeah i'm like
why would you tell your kid this that's
[ __ ] insane yeah like i yeah like
guys would go crazy in jail and like cut
their own nuts off and he was like
another day at the office jesus
a couple of keystone lights and trying
to put that away yeah yeah
something a little harder than keystone
lights did you smoke as a kid
cigarettes
uh here and there cigarettes because you
have i started smoking at six faces
right right yeah uh
no where i where i grew up it was mostly
snuff and uh chewing tobacco yeah yeah
yeah yeah like you ever chew
i dipped a little bit i like the pouches
a lot yeah the the those are my favorite
which is [ __ ] [ __ ] where i'm from
you gotta get some real skull or
copenhagen where i'm from were you cuz
you just got back from texas were you a
cowboy boots guy i never was you've seen
my feet i can't i can't i can't pull
them off i can't fit into them i always
wanted to be
like i wanted boots so yeah just shoot
them first
[Laughter]
dawning through another shoe again
oh my god oh how do we all right hold on
i would pin in the backstory how did
your feet get like that was there like
an egg oh are you did you
walk in acid or something what the
[ __ ] happening yeah like in robocop
what was there one x-men no um or just
years ago i'm still trying to figure out
exactly what it is but it looks like
it's a congenital it's something i might
i probably inherited it from my granddad
can you open anything with them or like
catch a football
like
[Laughter]
are you extending your toes or that's
just how they fall uh that's just how
they fall holy [ __ ] it's bad wow um yeah
he had uh
it was explained to me it's a form of
muscular dystrophy now i feel bad
no no no he's he's a piece of [ __ ] don't
worry he be he beat up my nana wait [ __ ]
that who are we talking about my grandpa
jesus christ uh but he um
yeah it was a form of muscular dystrophy
called
charco marie tooth
named after the scientists who
discovered it wait how is your
grandfather qualified to make this
diagnosis out of curiosity no he was a
doctor doctor he saw another his
grandfather had this he's assuming he
inherited we can't afford doctors
where i'm from
dr
dr quinn stops by all the time yeah
they're not spending all their money all
their money on movies [ __ ] i [ __ ] that
lineup um
yeah so i it looks like i inherited
whatever he had gotcha but none of the
swagger that
[Laughter]
my toes are pretty jacked up too but
nothing near like that but i got the one
bad toe everybody has the one bed oh
yeah i had to have my toenails removed
i've had they got so ingrown i had to go
to the doctor and have them pried off of
my body
anesthesia
guy next door did it yeah
union
union job yeah
i paid them cash we did it after hours
local 822 toe pullers right here
business is booming in texas
shout out to the pruitt family
wouldn't be able to feed my kids without
them i'll tell you that right now
they have a giant rat's foot outside
when they're on strike [ __ ] scabs
this is a local town
holy [ __ ]
oh that journey to journeyman toenail
pullers yeah
what the [ __ ] okay so back to the back
story your dad
so you're moving around with your dad a
lot and then you landed in texas so yeah
my dad was a prison guard and my mom
was a secretary up until
tennessee where we were landed in
tennessee we were in tennessee at the
time
uh she had some some health issues uh it
was actually a
miscarriage
and uh like how he laughs on that one
yeah i don't i don't know how else to
say it my mom had a miscarriage and kind
of went crazy and quit her job and just
never went back to work
but was was that was could your dad
support the family or was it like many
times were super tough no he
it was weird because like he we had
we were never like hurting like we
always had a roof food all that xbox
yeah yeah but uh there's three basics
yeah yeah
another three human rights yeah yeah we
had a cable box but um he was always
worried about money like he would he
would talk to me about his finances at a
very young age
this is too much of a small town
i mean you two probably were bellied up
at the bar in the barn together so who's
he going to talk to right yeah
yeah i i don't know looking back on it
it's very strange that he would like i
was a kid and he was like
man you know don't ever get in debt son
i'm like jesus all right
just listen dude just riding in the car
listening like dave ramsey with my dad
and he's like listen to this guy listen
to dave ramsey son
did you have brothers and sisters
uh
not
really
i don't know how to describe okay so
take your time
tell us everything so remember we're
trash from philly right all right yeah i
know yeah i'm the [ __ ] king compared
to this guy
so
my dad uh he was married before he met
my mom
uh to a woman and he had a son with her
who was my half brother
uh eric
and
uh their marriage fell apart because he
uh he was in the military and he went
overseas to
south korea not during any war it was
peace time i think but they were just
you know they had a little bit of r and
r i get it yeah
i don't know i don't know what he was
doing there
bachelor party he always talks about it
it was like in the 80s so it's like
there wasn't anything going on
in korea sure sex tourism i mean
theoretically there is it's you know
it's a tense situation between north and
south korea and they have a lot of
troops masked around the border okay so
it's a little bit of a dicey situation
okay fair enough he's making it sound
like his dad just went there to party or
hang out well because all of his stories
are like yeah man koreans know how to
drink
every story about korea is like the food
is good the women are good the drink is
good i'm like did you what did you do
that's a real sal thing the drink is
good yeah refer to it not like they got
good beers or anything soju i love it
brothers good drink so yeah so i got two
steps step brother i got two half
brothers yeah so what happens when he
gets back from korea uh his wife at the
time is pregnant and when when she gives
birth the baby is mexican and he's like
well
i'm not like i'm not making you half
brother eric my head no no no my half
brother eric already existed okay at
this point and then he gets back this is
all before you it's all before i come
into this world he returns i'm a twinkle
in his eye
[Laughter]
and so yeah so that their marriage falls
apart and then he meets my mom somewhere
down the line and he has me and so my
relationship with my brother
or half brother was just that he was
this guy who would come around every now
and then ask my dad for money
and my dad would just tell me about how
crazy his mom is yeah and would you ever
see the other kid the mexican eric no i
never saw any of that family i would
just hear stories about it like it was a
zoo
like my dad would talk about it like it
was this insane place that you just
never wanted to go to so i never saw
them but anytime my my half brother eric
would come visit he was like
he was a troubled kid or something
because he would just torture me he
would he he was a kid he kept snakes oh
man so that's another thing kept snakes
that doesn't make him sound like a pet
he kept him yeah he like he had that's a
tough that's a tough word choice
he kept snakes and good drink yeah
and so he would he would chase me around
with snakes holy what are you on jackass
what the i don't know he would just
change he would chase me around the
house with snakes when he would come
visit hi i'm talking pruitt somebody
calls social services
welcome to tennessee
holy [ __ ]
how much older than you was he he's like
he was 40.
actually
yeah he's almost 40 now yeah he's like
10 years older than that
he served in the military infantry and
then became uh like went to all the
hardcore training and became a sniper
damn
i got a buddy who became a sniper they
play by their own [ __ ] that's like
that's another kind of [ __ ] crazy
this is pre-sniper though when he was
torturing with the snake this was yeah
this was just him as a teenager i got
him in my
yeah get the rattlers this was just a
teenager
i knew rattlers would get him that's all
we were saying in texas all week um but
yeah this was he yeah because
this was way long ago we were still
living in georgia at the time when i
would see him
and the the moving around from town to
town which i can't imagine the towns are
that great because they're
near prisons yeah federal prisons
correct which typically are in the
middle of nowhere right
i mostly lived yeah near a prison so
just a [ __ ] town
like growing up my the town we lived in
uh in georgia the town i like spent the
first seven years
uh
the only thing that like the only
industry in that town other than the
prison was a paper mill so just smell
like [ __ ]
it was just like a [ __ ] the whole town
smelled like [ __ ] and my dad worked at
the prison
american hero
[Music]
there's a guy in a pickup truck let's do
this going this is my new favorite guy
yeah
i told you guys i'm like i i'm a kid in
a candy store right now because it's
like so did you have a garage fridge or
what's going on yeah
[Applause]
it was the lunchable situation
we ate paper
yeah kippy how about those helix
mattresses love them i know you're a big
fan i'm jelly i'm peanut butter and
jelly because i want one
take the quiz it's easy peasy they sent
us uh the two me and my me my lady got
the twilight mattress crazy best night
of my best night sleep i've ever had in
my life didn't know what i was missing
out on you don't got to go walking
around a mattress like a bozo you just
jump on there take a two-minute quiz
they match you up whether you sleep uh
hot cold whatever
cold spready yeah i could be sitting on
a plus right now
everybody's unique and helix knows it so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from soft medium firm
whatever you need they take the two
minute quiz they figure out they match
you exactly for you why are you gonna
buy a mattress that was made for someone
else what are we doing figure it out
it's 20 21 are we not human we got the
technology it's easy peasy um so if
you're looking for a mattress take the
quiz order the mattress your match to
the mattress comes right to your door
shipped free in a box never have to go
to the mattress store again you open it
up you feel cool you feel like james
bond or something yeah boom whoop i
still don't know how they ship them i
don't squeeze them in there and then
they come back to life they just got
like a huge giant that just and then
they put it in a box i think it's one
guy doing it a bunch of fat guys
helix is great but don't take our word
for it they were voted best overall
matches for 2020 by gq and wired
magazines
top-notch publications like we've said
um so just go to helixsleep.com
garbage take the two minute quiz get the
customized mattress you'll get the best
of the best sleep of your life 10 year
warranty the whole nine yards nice here
it is baby helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com garbage one more time up to
200 off all mattresses two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
garbage do it yeah
hey gang i'm here to talk about the good
folks over there at brooke linen baby
it's been a long tough couple of years
for everybody and we deserve some rest
and with brook linen they got breathable
sheets plush and absorbent towels cozy
robes comfy loungewear whatever you need
they have at brooklyn and works directly
with manufacturers to make luxury
available directly to you without luxury
level markup so you're getting an
amazing array of products at a
reasonable price
they sent me and my ladies some of the
sheets
they are fantastic i feel like i'm
staying at a five star six star seven
star resort sometimes when i'm rolling
around in these bad boys you gotta get
yourself some
you don't know what you're missing out
on until you get a good night's sleep
and brooke lennon is here to help
so give yourself the comfort and refresh
you deserve and get it for less at
brooklyn and go to brooklyn.com use
promo code garbage to get 20 bucks off
uh with a minimum purchase of 100 that's
brooklyn and b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n
and our promo code garbage for 20 bucks
off with a minimum purchase of a 100
that's brooklyn.com promo code garbage
do it raycon raycon raycon raycon raycon
everyday earbuds you're looking at a
proud owner of them never messed with
earbuds before until the raikons came
along pop them in they fit great in my
ear they sound absolutely fantastic and
from what i hear what's that they cost
half the price half of the leading bozos
yes skippy straighten them out recon
offers eight hours of play time and a 32
hour battery life so you're not
constantly running out of juice they
keep you juiced up long time you want to
listen to pods for a long time raycon's
want to listen to music for a long time
raycon they even got uh different
settings to make it uh to optimize your
listening
service i heard about this i didn't even
i didn't even know how smart they were i
got to start dabbling in baby steps for
you because what's cool is you you pop
them in and you're going you're cooking
yeah yeah they got pure mode for podcast
balance mode for like heavy metal rock
whatever and then if you want to bump
the mega bass the bass boost you get the
bass mode for hip hop edm reggae the
whole nine yards you wanna puff a little
chiba put on a little bob marley it's up
to you i like whatever you do i like
that edl i do weird every once in a
while um yeah guys like for the big man
said it's half the price of premium
audio brands but they sound just as good
45 day happiness guarantee and right now
ayg listeners can get 15 off the raycon
order at buy rakon.com garbage that's by
raycon dot com slash garbage and say 15
on raycon one more time write it down
buy raycon.com garbage do it
so you're settling in texas and
effectively you're you're an only child
correct growing up
are your parents still together now
yeah oh god they should
they shouldn't be
every time it sounds like a motorcycle
turning over there
yeah maybe i haven't hey look maybe
we're digging into some things i should
work through
no i'm kidding this is fun
uh yeah they're still gonna be crying in
a minute this is a great time
so you get to texas which by the way
love texas first time spending time
there we drove fantastic san antonio
austin houston fort worth fantastic
loved it yeah if you were to ask me like
what i consider home like when i think
of all the best memories i have mm-hmm
springtown springtown sounds like joke
yeah for sure just trying to get to
springtown
it's it's like hey joe dirk
it's like if you could see the i
remember there were there were days
after school that we would just go
just to have something to do we would
just go hang out at the sonic drive-in
yeah oh dude
i would screw up in the burbs so i was a
big just hanging at yeah the deli or
like a grocery store this exxon like the
you know the gas station yeah route 44
ocean water
what's that yeah stop trying to relate
to this i'm saying i understand that
there's nothing to do you go hang some
you don't know what a route 44 ocean
water is no so it's sauna how the [ __ ]
would i know oh sonic sonic the route 44
that's the 44 ounce and the ocean water
is like sprite with coconut it's really
good
man is that even legal yeah yeah 44
ounces
summer rolls around i'm getting an ocean
water yeah so what what else is in the
town so you got a sonic we have a son we
have a barn where underage drinking
happens we have a barn where there's a
prison somewhere in the vicinity there's
a
well i think
at this point
by the time we get to springtown my dad
finally
leaves the prison
and he gets a job at the bureau of
engraving and printing
where they like make money like print it
ah okay okay yeah and we have no idea
what anybody was like making trophies
no no it's where they have just trying
to class it up it was the bureau of no
it's a wreck your first place it's kind
of a cool place if uh you're interested
in money
so they yeah like a mint yeah yeah they
have all the plates they're playing like
the old artists and guys who like roll
them and print the money and you want
more security he was he was like a a
police officer on site there nice nice
yeah that's pretty cool what was the
what was the the gun situation growing
up did you shoot guns and stuff like
that of course yeah yeah yeah we would
uh texas comes correct when it comes to
guys well yeah texas but like my dad
grew up in georgia where
now
got you just bear with me on this what's
the the hunting that's big in that part
of the country i'm sorry what was that
word
hunting the hunting the hunting that's
big in that part of the country is is
what's known as [ __ ] hunting
that's raccoons raccoons right yes uh
and i've gone [ __ ] hunt with my dad a
couple times have you ever eaten
raccoons absolutely not okay i at least
have not eaten a raccoon but i've shot a
few and armadillos with already eating
armadillo i've not eaten an armadillo i
can eat an armadillo
i'm sure you can but yeah i've shot guns
for sure where are people eating the
raccoons that you hunt it no it's more
like a sport thing because it's like
those dogs those those [ __ ] hounds are
like
they're family in that part of the
country like if you have a [ __ ] house
that's like yeah it's like a so it's
like that's like a bonding activity with
your dog to like
take it out to the woods and it'll run
around so we're not talking atlanta
hitting a braves game and uh no
no
hitting the rhyming thing no we're talk
i mean we're talking like
truly in like like texas chainsaw
looking yeah like country is like
nowhere did you wear any of the raccoons
yeah any pelts
no a lot of like camo cargo shorts
i get that vibe yeah yeah well i saw you
not too long ago because i chose pizza
he had like an american bandana oh i've
got it wasn't he yeah dude
he looked like the fourth of july yeah
yeah
he had a cut off like american flag
shirt and bandana her add-on
man
every squirrel
i don't think i have i've eaten i i
think i've eaten snake
at like a restaurant though finally
finally got your step brother back huh
yeah
half brother hey eric
yeah
i mean there's i yeah there's a lot of
garbage here
like what else what else would you like
to know
i think i want to take a shower yeah
yeah you're gonna have to after this
wait i got a quick one yeah uh texas guy
just moved to the east coast bucky's
versus wawa where it is you're like
we just had our first [ __ ] thing
which we love like i'm both you are
[ __ ] i go buckies all day all day if
there was bucky's up here i'd be team
bucks
like what i love about uh texas but also
anywhere in the country really is like
regional
places sure yeah and bucky's is big for
me that's like you know when i think of
texas and home
every time we drove by one we were like
we're checking that's where we're going
yeah yeah so that's that's the same
situation with the wawa for us but here
was my question with bucky's bucky
seemed to be
it was a show it was you know there was
long lines there was all this can you
just walk in there
like as as somebody who like are there
any small buckies or were you driving
out to like the highway to go to bucky's
i would
yeah we're we're let me think because
when
we did see one or two smaller downsized
buckets what i want to know is as a
local kid
you know what i mean like we're there as
tourists you know we got a hat and we
waited in line for the kolaches or you
know whatever it is um but can you just
you know after school drive over grab a
sandwich and bucky's in two seconds in
the car and go home
usually no usually a bucky's is only
going to be on like the side of the
highway yeah yeah yeah you're right
also there's a lot of highway driving
intake
i picked up on it yeah yeah
flat [ __ ] highways yeah so i would
drive by bucky's like every day i drove
to college
he went to college yes very nice where'd
you go down there obviously yeah i went
to the university of north texas in
denton texas okay what'd you study
english okay i tried i started as a
biochemistry major what yeah kind of i
could i get that vibe too though i see
that for some reason just trying to make
math
i i try to learn a recipe to me to be
honest with you i i do think at the time
breaking bad was heading into like its
fourth season maybe and i was like well
i don't know
like i just have to go to college i
guess i'll
this guy makes science yeah
i really put i picked my major just
being like ah he does science that was
cool
but i ended up getting an uh english
degree
okay and just a step back what what's
your go to at bucky's what do you get oh
man well the barbecue sandwich for sure
okay uh the beaver nuggets that's a big
one i saw them there and i said this is
dalton's thing yeah that's what is that
like it's like a it's like a corn it's
like a sweet corn pop like a big
caramel i don't know
him i mean if you eat enough of them
it'll feel like there's a film on the
inside of your mouth okay
they make you queasy but they taste good
do you ever make them do you ever put
them in a bowl with milk as cereal i
it's that's too much i've tried it and
that was the first thing i thought
there's there's realms that should not
be explored
when it comes to food
because i that was too decadent i was
like this is this is way it's like did
you ever used to take like like there
was oreo cereal but did you ever used to
just take whole oreos and one hundred
percent
yeah i remember i remember
a girl i went to high school with
showed me that when i was in like eighth
grade she's like don't you ever do this
and it was it blew my mind it's it yeah
and it's like we shouldn't have access
no of course
because you go through a sleeve in about
30 seconds yeah for sure yeah but it's
unbelievable that's why i don't do
beaver nugget cereal don't want to cross
that yeah i don't want to cross that the
rubicon
once you open pandora's box yeah he's
closed he only wakes up from the matrix
once
[Laughter]
what were your grades in high school
b's and c's did you take the sats or
acts i took the s.a.t uh-huh what'd you
get was it and what was it it was out of
2400 i got like
18 something i don't even remember
you're a smart kid i i'm i i would say
as as trash is like truly white trash as
i am i've i'm smart
i'm like i read a lot i'm pretty smart
but i am trash which is a commandment to
your character because from what you're
telling me if i was looking at this on
paper
uh
you know english teacher comedian or
biochemist wouldn't be the career i
would say i i see bomb maker yeah
i see bomb maker serial killer yeah sure
guy with a bone to pick yes yeah yeah
bell tower or something yeah yeah you
got a real bell tower vibe too yeah yeah
for sure so that's um
that's saying a lot overcoming obstacles
i get i get i get a lot of uh i get real
same talent vibes from them
you know you know what i i listen to
this show country you know the country
aspect i listen to this show and sam's
is the only episode i was like oh i
think he might be the only person in
comedy trashier than i am yeah sam
sam we love you buddy yeah
all right so you got sonic you got
buckies what else
what else is in the town uh well there
there was no buggies in springtime that
was a drive
i don't want to make it seem like we
were but in yeah we weren't this was not
a bucky's town this was a we had a
brookshire's that was a grocery store is
that where you went that's where your
mom went to the store that's where we
went to go again
berkshires brookshires yeah was it a
nicer place or like like even as a kid
it was the only place to buy groceries
in the town so did they sell anything
other than groceries was there any kind
of feed or i feel like no this is
because we there actually was a a a
whole feed store okay town square get
your deer yeah yeah yeah yeah
your deer there was also what is deer
corn deer corn isn't that that one it's
just corn yeah it's just corn you have a
you have a deer lease are you familiar
with a deer lease
no or a deer or a deer blonde it's got a
kia yeah oh yeah deer leaves is like
a forte so deer leaves is like when you
go when you go hunting uh-huh uh it's
like a
really it's like a tree house like a big
metal tree house
yeah to snipe deer really but the corn
is like you have feeders out on the
property where they come too and you
fill those up with corn and you there's
all kinds of different feeders but some
you could just set to like go
like spit it out and it attracts the
deer and then you kill them and then you
have and then you have meat for the
winter yeah it's like a deer lick deer
meat guy
i like it yeah yeah yeah i don't i i
never really went hunting like that like
i wasn't i uh
i never raccoon was the biggest game you
find raccoon is the biggest game i've
hunted because like all hunting is is
expensive it's like a rich kids thing
yeah no i know what you mean yeah and so
i you gotta have all the gear you gotta
get there i'm not dude i know how funny
that sounds i'm not a cross in texas i'm
not joking all of my friends that could
afford to go hunting i was so jealous of
i was like i just can't my family can't
we don't have hunting money yeah we're
not you know
you're not down sweatpants
it's just shooting the raccoons in the
trash can you got a blazer on it's also
hunting in texas also is a lot of it is
just it's a great excuse to drink sure
four o'clock in the morning yeah it's
like fishing it's the same thing it's a
[ __ ] hang on oh fishing now that's
that's what i like yeah
yeah right like what like pot like lakes
and [ __ ] what are you going for
i grew up fishing too yeah well when i
was a when i was real little before we
even went to texas we uh my dad and i
would just walk to like a creek i love
that with the fishing poles like andy
griffith
is in black and white too yeah yeah did
you have you ever gone what's it called
canoodling or doodling where are you
noodling
no that's a whole different breed of
white chicken billy yeah yeah no
yeah
fishing's good good old-fashioned fish
good clean fun even as we got older me
and my buddies be like we've been like
let's just go get two cases of beer act
like we're fit like you know throw a
line and we'll just sit in the woods and
drink for [ __ ] six hours was there a
pool at your house you guys have a pool
never what was the house like what was
like was it like i don't know it was
always changing
it was a hologram yeah kid could never
find his bedroom it was a different
house like every two years
what what did were they like single
homes were they apartments condos or
were there were they like those
stereotypical like ranchers it was all
over the place there were times we live
in a house times it was an apartment
i think at one point we lived in a
trailer wow uh it's pink at once it's
hard yeah because it's like we bounced
around so much like early early on
that's hard for me to remember all of it
but when you got to texas you like do
your parents to live in the same house
that you grew up in in texas no no they
live in arkansas now what the [ __ ] yeah
this has witsec all over it
jesus christ it's real they moved they
moved to arkansas because my dad said he
wanted to try and quit drinking in
arkansas medicinal marijuana so now they
live in arkansas and my dad gets just
gets drunk and smokes weed
how you put this [ __ ] together it's
a-okay
his plan was to smoke weed to help him
quit drinking but now he's just addicted
to two things that's great
that's such a [ __ ] southern thing to
me too or like country thing of like
well i'm going to move because i want to
quit like you can't do that insane yeah
that's crazy my dad's insane
i had to get out of texas didn't you
live in a dry county yep
but that house the texas house yeah
that was a single family home correct
yeah does that have a barn how many
acres did you have we we
i guess for the town we were in we would
be considered uh poor because we only
had one acre and we had neighbors
which is bad in my where i'm from yeah
you want the land you want the land if
you have neighbors
you're [ __ ] up just i spit on that
neighbors
yeah we had an acre and uh
you know is that is that in like a
little cul-de-sac
all right yeah yeah yeah what was the
street yeah it was a street name
portwood no no no
was it
we had so many different places
it was arbor arbor court
that's that doesn't sound like a quartz
class it wasn't it was not a bad house
if
we had ever finished unpacking oh it
would have been great you never finished
unpacking everywhere i lived as a kid
there were always unpacked boxes oh
[ __ ] my dad was always on the move even
when even like
we lived there from like fifth grade
till i graduated and still boxes he was
still boxes and he was always like all
right i'm gonna get it up on the market
any day now he was always thinking he
was always thinking like he's yeah and
it was always like all right i'm putting
the house up on the market that was a
conversation that was had for years damn
until it finally you know he sold it and
now they live
had half stuff was already packed too
that's easy yeah yeah out the door you
know what do they live in arkansas now
what kind of house i don't know i
haven't been yet
when did they move holy [ __ ]
that's a tragedy i've ever heard in my
life
i don't know what kind of house your
parents
never been to your parents house well
they
how long do they move there like a few
months ago okay okay
they had moved a few months is fine like
they
in they had moved from texas back to
georgia because my dad had gotten a job
as a like a police trainer
and then he did that till he retired
it was so he only did it for like six
months and they moved to arkansas
and i just haven't gotten a chance to go
out there yet that's fair enough yeah
yeah i'll give you that i'll give you
that i mean if you were like they were
living there for five years i'd be like
you gotta go home and see the see the
family uh did your mom cook growing up
yeah she actually cooked that was like
she prided herself on uh her homemaking
abilities
except for unpacking the box except for
unpacking the boxes
uh yeah she cooked a lot uh a lot of a
lot of good home cooking you know like
greens and uh rice and tomatoes and
would she make breakfast for you before
you went to school
um
yeah a lot
a lot of mornings she would like because
i didn't want to eat breakfast
and she would insist on cooking me like
a breakfast burrito
or something like that what am i
good way to start the day yeah would you
pack your lunch or buy lunch at school
uh i always just bought it at school
okay very rarely did i pack a lunch
because i just i didn't like carrying it
around yeah i hated that yeah i felt
like a door dude you feel like the
biggest goober walking around with the
laundry yeah good school system my dick
wet over here um
yeah it actually kind of for for what
the town was like no the answer is no
but for what circumstantial circumstance
it was a it's a better school than you
would think okay
but there were still kids who uh died
that's every high school yeah yeah we
lost a couple how
uh let's see eighth grade one kid
climbed up on a natural gas tank and lit
a match and he exploded
uh
what happened to drowning in the
community
a good old-fashioned overdose
yeah
oh holy [ __ ] 12th 12th grade my friend
ryan did you do it on purpose the kid
would i i never found out it was him and
his buddy and his body was like
just there and just saw him blow up it
was like what and then he ran to like
the nearest business and was like hey uh
my friend just um exploded
henry done blowed up yeah
holy [ __ ] there was a
sound cloud what are we talking about
here yeah
12th grade my friend ryan he got a gun
accident shot in the head
okay um any electrocution or anything
dude
it's so that uh uh back in ape damn oh
so [ __ ] i'm sorry i had no idea yeah oh
you're freaking out i know i did i do
i don't do you guys want to talk about
i'm i'm fine talking about it but i it's
up to you this is a this is a comedy
show so sorry [ __ ] i could go it by the
way you guys would love that whole saga
i just i know the vibe of this show and
i don't know if y'all want to hear all
of that
it's i don't know i'm sorry i don't know
but it's up to
that is exactly how my friend got killed
oh my god i'm so sorry
he was a yeah he was an electrician
working a job in midland texas at a at a
sam's club
you guys know about sam i know sam's
club and i know midland yeah yeah yeah
yeah so uh combine the two and you get
uh i guess death
[Laughter]
yeah he um
it was just a faulty
wiring a light fixture yeah and it it
zapped him
and uh even at
it's it's
i'm laughing because the story is funny
because we buried him
and then two days later i got a call
from his wife and was like she goes you
are not going to believe this
but the funeral home made a mistake and
we buried eric in the wrong grave oh my
god
dig them up and put them so home had to
go back out there and move him not
personally she went out there to make
sure nobody stole his boots oh my god
that's a big thing with electricians
though a big thing with electricians is
your boots for some reason because i
used to work oh no that's a texas thing
but i used to work construction even up
here i used to work construction and
there would be guys like cutting wires
because like they'd be like oh is it
this or this and they would they would
oh no he was buried in his cowboy boots
boots he wasn't buried in the boots he
would be like died my boots to make sure
my wife gets my boots yeah the boots
that were melted onto
still smoking
you know that's horrible i'm so sorry
that happened to you but yeah that is
hysterical well okay so get this but
there's more
walmart they own sam's club they send
his wife a letter
and all it says is something like we're
sorry you had a bad experience at one of
our stores
[Music]
dude it's like the milk was experienced
yeah here's a 25 gift card where i come
from is a is a william faulkner novel
it's just tragic tales of the south
dude yeah hey kevin answer your question
yeah there were some elections
i've done that a couple times or i'm
like this question might go south [ __ ]
it went south i mean you you you brought
me in i'm i'm south i mean the kid
blowing up with the gas line that's what
i thought
that's what i'm like oh someone must
have like got an electric electrocuted
on a fence or something well there was
one kid who was like
surfing on the back of a truck like teen
wolf yeah i like that and but then when
the truck uh took a he barreled out of
it into a fence and died jesus christ
but there was a downside
you wanna know the best part though i i
remember driving by it and the way i
remember it is there was a kid-shaped
hole in the fence like
that's great
love that
oh god what was a pruitt family vacation
looking like down there jesus it was a i
can't imagine it was the four seasons
dude it was our vacations big disney
world family we did go to disney world
really because i was an only child so it
was like it was like we had the funds it
was easier to remember every trash
family goes to disney world at least
once yeah but it was like we had the
money to do fun things but they never
felt fun because of who my family are it
was just like it's a lot of fun it was
just like i brought you to disney world
are you going to enjoy it or not smile
yeah yeah
see if i could score weed
um
yeah the vacations were like there were
there were some
years we would just go back to my dad's
hometown just to see my grandma and stay
at that house just stay at her apartment
oh her apartment
uh
and then there's a town in florida we
went to a lot called uh saint augustine
that was i feel like i know that that
was a regular vaca is the oldest city in
america that's probably yeah that's
probably why um well what's there to do
there is it near the beach i want to
look at old forts yeah pirates it's not
is it near the beach it is on the it's a
really beautiful city okay uh we would
go there a lot
um
i think i remember one year when i was
like 1920 we went to new orleans
which is an awful place to go with your
parents at any age but especially when
you're not drinking age because i had to
have my dad with me to order any alcohol
like they'll let you drink if you're
underage as long as you have your parent
with you
so i kept having to grab my dad and go
hey i want to i want to get a grenade
will you come with me to buy me
a cocktail
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] drinking with your
parents on vacation oh yeah oh that was
vacations at a certain point as a
teenager it was like
just a place to go drink
like all of us did your mom booze too
all of us yeah wow
heavy heavy quite the tale did you work
as a kid did you have a do you have a
summer job or anything like that yeah i
got my first job when i was 17. i got uh
at the we had one of these in springtown
a subway oh okay
i was a sandwich artist yeah
which is a fun job when you're a
teenager and just like
don't have any responsibilities because
i i mean i was straight up stealing
cookies
all the like not even not even cooked
cookies i would go in the freezer and
like a mouse just eat cookie dough
out of the boxes get that [ __ ] all the
time yeah yeah is it was it oh does
spunkmeyer cookies bring a chance
no subway has their own like proprietary
cookie uh
recipe it was i used to
i used to go all out at subway i would
make myself a blt but with like 35
strips of bacon it was awesome this
guy's making sense best summer of my
life together best summer of my life
dude going out back eating my uh big ass
blt smoking an apple black and mild with
brian who was also at the subway that
was a fun summer
we used to i worked at this restaurant
and we would have to go into the
walk-ins and clean them so we'd go in
with a bucket of soapy water and that's
why they kept like the desserts and the
creme brulee so i'd go in there with a
spoon in my pocket we just eat like
[ __ ] 15 creme brulees and just throw
them in the bucket hell yeah no one's
none the wiser
yeah that's the best part working like
fast food is just eating as much as you
want oh 100 yeah the death of me
it was every russian i worked that i
hated work i hated eating there just cuz
like what you just get the [ __ ]
that's too much of it you see i get that
yeah i'm just like you see how the
sausage is made and i'm like i can't eat
here anymore you know yeah not for me
all right let's give him some more you
garbage
have we not gotten
for an hour i've been asking him
questions actually yeah i feel like i
really i feel like i threw you guys off
with all this
one for you which we've done before and
i feel this is gonna this will pay off
this will how do you hold a pencil
like this oh normal way oh you got a
long ass fingernails though you got to
cut down oh yeah holy [ __ ]
you know a chicken picker
out there
[Laughter]
are you a nail cutter or nail biter
spider yeah you gotta go ahead
it baffles me when somebody is like i'm
trying to quit biting my nails it's like
i've
never even thought about it i'm just
always chomping on my mind i love it
yeah that's great trust me when you
let one grow real long and you get a
nice nice bite nice yeah well i'm trying
to yeah i'm trying to uh finger i'm
trying to play flamingo guitar let's get
to pick up yeah yeah yeah is that true
no i didn't i did try in high school
played the trumpet i i grew them out in
high school because i was trying to
learn how to finger pick and the
principal made me cut him he was like
boy he was invincible yeah he was like
boy those them nails is too long you're
gonna hurt somebody with them things
i'm not he's not hollering
he really said that he was like i want
to see you cut him holy [ __ ] he watched
you cut him yeah he wanted to make sure
i cut my nails good lord
uh i got a quick one moving around a lot
did you ever have you ever slept in a
murphy bed
like a fold out yeah
no no it folds out of the wall yeah yeah
i don't know i slept in murphy bed but
i've slept on tons of like
you know hotel fold out couches in the
same room as my parents
man so on vacation one room sometimes
yeah sometimes it would be like they
would get the bed and i would get the
fold-out couch yeah
been there yeah
anyone in your family collect marble
miles
ever
i don't know if anyone ever had marlboro
money my aunt always smoked sky dancers
it sounds like the bootleg blue angels
the sky dancers yeah
i give it up for the sky dances
they're all different players yeah i
don't i dance what the [ __ ] is this it's
like the knock off american spirit it's
got like a little chief on the cover of
it on the box
the cover
oh yeah wow sky dancers oh
yeah i i don't know if anyone ever had
more they only come in hundreds yeah
that's what it looks like yeah that's my
aunt always smokes those and then other
than that it was always like
okay you know we were a camel family oh
and sky dancers i assume didn't have a
rewards program no they didn't it was
just like a three dollar pack of
cigarettes that was your reward were you
a crystal light family growing up
crystal light yeah yes for sure crystal
light and then when mio came out that
was a big day wait is that the juice
this bottle that you squeeze that's
trash
you did that at home
yeah mio
he just got someone yeah mia that's
supposed to be in like a in like a
single thing of a bottle of water that
you drop a couple in there you're making
pictures no no no like you you would
have bottles of water and just you have
the meal so you have like a
juice what was the water situation in
your house was it bottled
um yeah it was always bottled my parents
my parents always bought bottled water
they didn't trust the tap water well
that's where we were just in fort worth
right and they said don't yeah they told
us to drink it he was like you could
roll the dice with it i don't know i i
i've never had any problems with tap
water anywhere i've ever gone okay other
than
amarillo texas which is where my mom
grew up so we would go there we went
there every christmas and whatever is
going on in that town they do have
noticeably disgusting water
like truly it's it's like visibly yeah
cloudy it tastes like [ __ ] it's it's
like i how does anyone live here
home of the city
the same question yeah well there's the
amarillo is the home of the 72-ounce
steak i don't know if you're familiar
with them i don't but i wish i would
have stopped by
72 ounces yeah the big text and they got
your name on the wall or whatever yeah
you have to eat it on a stage in front
of everyone on a stage yeah yeah and if
you look for amarillo texas if you can
finish it in under an hour it's free and
you get your name do a lot of people is
it like a it's like a tourist attraction
but do people accomplish it often or is
it one of those things where it's like
once again because they they this is how
they get you this is this is the 72
ounce steak scam
uh you have to eat not just the steak
but all the sides yeah
load you up on taters
um let's see do you eat your pizza crust
uh yes if if we're at like a nice place
or ordering in like dominoes or whatever
but it was always um you guys ever go to
like a cc's i've been one the cece's
pizza buffet that was where you didn't
eat the you don't want to load up on the
bread well no you keep the crust as
tallies for how many people slices
you've eaten
and that's that's like the competition
you have with your friends on a field
trip just so you can eat the most pizza
slices what would be considered a nice
place like a nice pizza place yeah the
pizza buffet
[Laughter]
okay
check please t-bone
now you're 28 years old yeah
when
that's not still in operation is it the
pizza plate the pizza
i do remember their buffet i remember
going to some as a kid and it being like
remarkable yeah
it was they were that was the best thing
the thing i was scared of is that your
hometown still happened still did it
um
no they didn't have the buffet okay well
mine had it up until
up through high school mine had it the
90s is fine no but that was 2004. really
yeah because we would good lord we would
cut school and go there damn or like
leave school early and go to pizza
buffet i thought they canceled them
before night court was off the air holy
[ __ ]
um what were the pets what was the pet
situation
so
uh other than the snakes other than the
snakes so we would like we would get
dogs
but then
at some point the word get dogs it's the
word choice is so strange in the sense
well because like my people get them
because my dad would bring home a dog
like we had a beagle moe
yeah and then one day
mo wasn't there
and my dad told my dad told me uh he
gave me the you know i sold him to a
farmer okay
but then
never revealed that that wasn't the case
at no point ever told me the dog was
actually just dead sure
and he like i was running around the
neighborhood for two weeks like riding
my bike running around looking for this
dog
and then he finally was like hey moe's
not coming back i just like seeing you
get the exercise jeez
this guy's all about life lessons
don't trust the banks i like the
exercise but that was always
if the dog didn't die it was like he
would just end up giving the dog away
because we would have to move at some
point ah that makes sense and so we
didn't actually have like a family pet
until i was a freshman in high school we
got a shih tzu
named gizmo who by some miracle is still
alive to this day
i mean by every method of veterinary
science my mom is keeping this thing
like the cloudy eyes oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah just in a chamber
huh okay ever bring an animal from
outside into the house and then raise it
as a pet
i tried for sure they didn't make it no
they would my parents would actually one
time yeah i i found a cat on the street
and that became our cat chester uh so i
you know what i just remember gizmo was
the second family he was gizmo was the
only dog we ever kept okay and chester
was the only cat we ever kept to
completion chester like died okay we
kept it until you didn't give it away
yeah yeah because like we also had cats
too i remember crying my eyes out
because like we had these three kittens
that our calico had given birth to
and i love these kittens and then one
day my parents took me to a place and
they were like all right say bye to the
kittens
and i was like what what kind of place
was it it was just like an adoption
center but they they were like we have
to give the kittens away yeah it's too
many yeah they were like they're getting
in the walls and eating insulation
these kittens like would like they would
just show they sound like possums
probably three men
the kittens would like their faces would
get swollen in their eye because they
were eating insulation my parents were
like we gotta get rid of these [ __ ]
things that makes sense where in the
house was there open insulation i don't
know i guess the attic
this kid's something else
do you have a passport no okay i never
have any plan on getting one i would
like to travel abroad okay
do you take pills dry or do you drink
water with them
it depends uh i can i can and have taken
them dry for sure but i i enjoy taking
them with water i enjoy what uh do you
own any do you want a pair of dress
shoes at the moment i do i have a pair
of wing tips oh okay uh suit yeah you
wanna see i do not own a suit okay if
you were gonna get dressed so you gotta
hey [ __ ] i have a wedding tomorrow what
are you what can you pull together out
of your closet
nothing nothing no dude i got to go to
joseph a bank
a tuxedo or some steve harvey yes rent a
tuxedo i don't know some steve harvey
suits police it's a lisa suit
uh i don't know if i've ever actually
needed a suit that's like that's such a
southern [ __ ] to me because the way we
all like formal attire where i'm from is
like cowboy cowboy jeans buttons pearl
snip button down yeah yeah
which is a great look like like my
friend's funeral that was how like most
people were dressed yeah like the cowb
like yeah that's how i was dressed i had
like a johnny cash shirt on okay yeah
yeah yeah i love that and
black though black yeah all black that's
not a [ __ ] answer that was that was
the thing before he died he always
demanded i he said i want everybody
dressed in all black i will be mourned
properly
damn
[Laughter]
he's
got some old souls that's a tough
outlook
no no no he was it was always a joke but
that was like came to fruition yeah yeah
right
sorry what's the next question
what's your dairy queen order
oh the steak finger basket
i meant ice cream but okay
can you put some sprinkles in the steak
finger basket
he goes hot meal holy [ __ ]
is
what was it again what is it called the
steak finger basket what the [ __ ] is
that it's fried steak fingers with
french fries two pieces of toast and
gravy oh man it sounds delicious it's
awesome what the [ __ ] is a steak finger
i don't know dude it's i
it must be a texas thing because when i
went to dairy queens up here i was like
where is the steak finger bastard i
talked to y'all man yeah can i talk to
y'all's manager about the steak finger
situation at this dairy queen i might
just be your dairy queen
armadillo's
dq
is is like a kind of a texas thing 100
oh is that yeah yeah yeah because like
when i was growing up it it was always
like dq that's what i like about texas i
didn't know what was this that was our
that was the song
that some lunatic would sing on his
front porch yeah yeah
so
yeah when i like my favorite i guess my
favorite thing to order at dairy queen
is the steak finger basket followed by
uh yeah blizzard for sure
oreo originally
okay
heath that's a gentleman's choice um
have you ever been trying to pair as
well with the steak knuckles steak
knuckles with the pigs now oh well have
you ever have you ever heard had a pit
pickled pig's feet
no
no
no you know hormel
sure they make the chili they also make
something that was a
staple in the pruitt household called
pickled pig's feet i gotta look them up
they make the chili yeah yeah
and uh
pickled pig's feet was always something
i enjoyed oh i've seen that for sure i
think there's a jar of that in my garage
oh my god that thing that's what you're
talking about are they cooked is that
cooked yeah yeah you can eat that right
out of the jar
the best part no you can't yes yes you
can not in new york you're not allowed
yes the best part
let me tell you the best part about
pickled pigs feet you eat them have you
a little snack put them in the fridge
you know the red what's left pull them
back out of the fridge later all the
brine has congealed around the pig's
foot so you get like a salty jello
before you get to dig back into your
pig's foot
just ruined my day
holy [ __ ]
i know that gelatin that you're talking
about that's not good yeah
it's pork jelly
it's not jelly
ain't making it yeah
[Laughter]
don't get a pb and j at the brewer house
yeah you want a peanut butter and pig's
foot sandwich
extra hoof for me
aren't there bones in there yeah you eat
around the bone there's meat on the
there's meat on the bone kevin is the
skin on the foot is there a nail like
there's a hoof
you find a wedding ring in there
what other weird [ __ ] do you eat being a
vienna sausages that's disgusting
okay i mean can you top the pig's feet i
believe he can i believe in this young
man what else
um i wha what's weird i mean i don't
know
like head cheese i've eaten head cheese
yeah [ __ ] pork brains
dude that's like indiana jones
oh when we would go fishing you know
when a big boulder's rolling behind you
just got to get your pigs
when we would go fishing this that one
of the trip like a real treat was if you
were gutting a fish and it had eggs
like grabbing those fish eggs and frying
them up that was always good
that i that i can't i'll give you a fry
i know you were just going to slurp them
i would have cut i would have pulled the
plug on the cameras
uh have you ever had alcohol that you
that someone made in their house of
course great question yeah yeah like
moonshine or like bathtub gin like
whatever i've had moonshine like a guy
had made it in like a big like home
depot bucket
and um we were definitely underage it
was my my friends girlfriends
dad
we were all at their house and he
gave us some flavor was always like
mixed with like a parasite
tastes like [ __ ]
it's not pinnacle yeah dude
it's [ __ ] call up diddy let's get
some sorak in here it's booze made in a
home depot bucket and we were 18.
but i've watched a lot of moonshine
drywall screwed
yeah uh
i'm a big moonshiners fan on a e or
whatever it was
oh [ __ ] all right um god is there a
crawl space in the home
um
no what's a crawl space that's a no ah
it's like in the basement oh no we
didn't there's no basements storm
shelter
tornado shelter or anything like that no
just go in the bathroom
or a closet
have you ever uh watched the implosion
of a building
not in person but that was a thing in
dallas like they would uh it was like a
spectacle yeah whenever they would blow
up a building
sure they'd come forward have you have
you and your family ever sat and watched
the house burn
together like if something caught on
fire you ever stand around and watch it
like
our home not your home
oh yeah yes if something's on fire and
then oh if there's a fire here go you're
going to watch like when zach blew up
from the gap from the natural gas tank
we were yeah we saw the black smoke
rising and we were like
must be another kid must be zach again
pig's feet we're coming out
um have you ever been to a byob strip
club yes okay recently
uh no okay when i was like
18. cool that passes
what was your first car
um
what
it was a
chevy silverado oh like 99 at 98.99
that's not too
shabby no it wasn't bad
and then after that like uh my dad gave
me let me he didn't give it to me let me
drive his 98 lexus until i totaled it
wait a minute wait a minute your dad had
a lexus yeah we were like
like the next evolution of white trash
like my dad grew up dirt dirt poor
like like what you read about
in the south yeah and then my family was
like if you gave that guy money okay so
yeah there was a lexus um
my dad
always was buying [ __ ] way above his
means and it was a used lexus i presume
right he didn't buy a brand new left
yeah yeah yeah um
what else would he buy
uh he was big on like home theaters
like
it was it was always like a a very tense
in the house when he was picking out a
home theater
when he was picking out new speakers and
receivers and stuff we were in the
magnolia room
uh weekly trying to find the right one
what's the magnolia room you don't know
about the magnolia room no i assume it's
some sort of oh it's a theater
my home theater no at best buy they have
uh the magnolia room oh the glasses yeah
yeah gotcha
wow he would like go in there and sit
there and
hold yeah yeah he would just go in there
and go man look at how cool this looks
and it's just like footage of frogs just
jumping around
the future
oh god
i mean i think i've
is there anything else you want to know
is there anything else you think we
should know is there anything we're
missing
uh i don't even know what kind of
injuries did you sustain as a child
well my feet
um seemed more of natural causes yeah
yeah
uh i do i do remember one time
and this is something my family still
makes fun of me for even though i was a
little kid
uh i was awesome
[Laughter]
i was barreling down uh someone's
driveway on a like a razor scooter okay
and just
like blazing fast
uh
as i remember it hey i i and i went to
look for the break with my foot and i
couldn't find it
and i wasn't aware that
like the
like you can't just plant your foot on
the ground to stop it
because i did that and it flung me off
of it and i i like slammed into the
pavement and like skidded
and like ripped all the skin off of like
my elbow and my hand and all that but i
didn't even notice that at first because
like i hit the ground so hard it knocked
the wind out of me mm-hmm and just as a
kid i was like
dad i knocked my lungs out and he was
like
that dude that's not possible
i know that dumbass yeah you can't knock
your lungs out you dumb [ __ ]
would you guys go out to eat as a family
yeah we actually my dad would uh would
take us to like nice restaurants
uh
like
there was a place in downtown fort worth
we went to a lot called texas day brazil
so i think we saw that when we were down
there yeah brazilian state yeah okay
that was fun um we actually yeah we
weirdly enough we did go eat a lot of
nice meals
like we we would go into places that
we
didn't it like didn't make sense that we
were there he was gonna say it doesn't
make sense it doesn't it doesn't mean he
said it doesn't make sense
it doesn't make it a damn bit of sense
that we love the rhythm of the texas
accent it's great what about christmas
christmas was usually
uh we would drive up to my mom's
hometown to spend it with like all of
that family would you decorate the house
though for christmas season
no
usually
my mom would buy like a fake little tiny
tree to just put on the table or
something and in table what yeah
i wonder if they do it texas like this
yes no yeah texas goes big on christmas
my family just didn't okay yeah we would
drive up to amarillo and just spend
christmas there with the bad water where
would they where would they put the
presents for you when you came down in
the morning well there it
uh usually for those christmases there
would be a tree but like okay at our
house there was never like a real tree i
guess because if you were going there
anyway you're going away from so you
would actually sleep there christmas eve
at your grandmother's all right we would
usually yeah we would usually either
stay with a family member or get a hotel
dude that's like cousin eddie that's
like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
man
anything else missing any teeth
uh no i'm not
not that i'm aware of i just i haven't
been to a dentist in probably like 12
years yeah it's been a long time did you
have braces no i never did
hmm
i had
i got
the silver caps when i was a kid yeah
that hurt i had those wait the caps are
the fillings like the i don't know i had
silver teeth as a kid yeah they used to
put i had a cap at one point yeah yeah
so did my brother yeah [ __ ] yeah it's
like then they fall out they fall out
yeah it's your baby teeth so they just
fall out anyway i remember once yeah i
just had like one day it fell out and i
had a little piece of jewelry with a
rotting tooth in it what'd you do with
the silver do you remember
i think i killed a werewolf
melted it down made a bullet i
yeah the tooth had to come out we were
under attack
get the smelter yeah
oh my god dalton pruitt
i mean 100
garbage yeah yeah but legendary oh
fantastic do you think you think this is
gonna be a legendary one this is a good
one this is the first text this is the
first
proper texas guy we've had right this is
the first pig's feet i think
that's come across our desk i'm coming
into this i was like i don't even know
how i'm going to fit in
like anything because it's all just
everything yeah it's garbage everything
every decision that was ever made in
your life
yeah yeah
it's like you and tom takar for the
heavyweight championship yeah yeah yeah
sam talent as well we gotta have you
back for another party sam is my boy
sam's the best i love that guy yeah
sam's fantastic
all right so you got the loud boys
podcast what else you want to focus out
there tonight yeah plug any shows or any
social media anything yeah uh patreon
patreon.comloudboys um we have our live
stand-up show
uh it's called brooklyn's cool
it's at the brooklyn comedy club in
williamsburg the next one's going to be
on october 10th cool nice uh obviously
skankfest the weekend after skankfest
we're going to be at laughing up
poughkeepsie very nice
um and then other than that uh i'm doing
merch now so be on the lookout for the
t-shirts nice cool awesome support these
guys they're super funny the podcast is
awesome they're working hard they're
doing their own young hustlers baby
gotta [ __ ] love that uh what a fun
episode what a crazy
[ __ ] tale of woe
i want to give you a hug if you want to
come if you want to come to my parents
this year for christmas you are more
than invited okay gotta keep your socks
on though
we can't have the dog chewing on him
please don't feed my cat insulation
kevin what do you got for him guys thank
you so much uh just you know patreon
youtube itunes the whole [ __ ] nine
yards come out to our live show uh we
got philly and we're announcing a new
york city show very [ __ ] soon uh
might even be on the beginning of this
episode check it out thanks guys we love
you guys we'll see you next week peace